what's up GQ it's a little Dicky aka
sunscreen GQ asked me to show you guys
how to freestyle
unfortunately I'm like a horrible
freestyler so what I can do is tell you
five useful tips to maintain a healthy
relationship because I'm good at that
the first tip is honesty I mean if you
can't be honest with your significant
other or your soon-to-be significant
other I suppose then you're dating the
wrong person like you should very easily
be able to say exactly what you feel and
hope that the other person understands
where you're coming from the second tip
to a healthy and sustainable
relationship is to have very practical
useful flights both parties kind of have
to look at a fight as like a useful tool
to find a great common ground
I loved fighting with my girlfriend's
ex-girlfriends don't get sensitive or
weird or like you know shut down because
of a fight that's being a baby grow up
and fight the third useful component to
a healthy relationship is sex you really
have to have that like spark that fling
that like you walk into a room and like
maybe like pants start getting on button
two all of a sudden like that has to be
like a factor it's got to be like
potential because if it could never
happen it's so boring and I don't know
you're just you're gonna lose a lot of
the excitement I think you got to live
kind of spontaneously the fourth factor
to a healthy relationship is really
selflessness it has to be selfless you
got to see it from the other side the
other point of view and really do things
that help her or him I can't be all
about you the fifth tip I have for you
in terms of a healthy relationship is
loyalty you should be dating someone
that this thought of cheating on them
would like really like wound you inside
if you're not with that person you're
with the wrong person so that's all I
got a young when I hear these
[ __ ] on the radio they ball are
[ __ ] Cuba Gooding up and radio along
for the moment I could say it's not
debatable and past that I wonder who
appreciate it like a snapchat Aflac duck
the dude I'm going hard for the grind
but I took this move I made a wall with
the rhymes [ __ ] your crew these [ __ ]
go in Adolf trying to [ __ ] this Jew see
ya